let's jump into this first story all
right we got this from timcast.com Biden
Administration says air near derailed
train and controlled chemical burn is
safe amid concerns of water
contamination as soon as I read that
headline I could hear Luke Rutkowski
screaming at the top of his lungs all
the way from Florida
because uh as you know they said the air
was safe to breathe on 9 11 which it
absolutely was not and so the reason in
my opinion they would tell you the air
is safe to breathe is because they want
you to go work to solve that problem hey
look I get it you got a problem if
nobody wants to go and work to put the
fire out and stop the chemical spill
then it keeps getting worse but you're
not going to convince someone to go do
it if you tell them the truth about how
toxic the air is the Ohio Department of
Natural Resources reports the 3500 fish
in the area have died since the
derailment photos of a actually I think
I have a photo right here is this uh do
I have the photo okay here's the rain
here it's the radius Wall Street Silver
says the cloud radius of the chemical
burn in Ohio is huge yup we're in it
because uh most of you know we're in the
uh we're in Western Maryland West
Virginia so we're we're absolutely
getting hit by this and I think I think
we have a picture of this is Spike Cohen
he says I am infinitely more concerned
with the Raging chemical fire in East
Palestine is it East Palestine is that
it is Palestine Ohio oh wow that I am
with the NORAD playing whack-a-mole with
balloons you know I'm I'm deeply
concerned about this toxic plume of of
chemical gas this is the controlled burn
they did this on purpose are you for
real I'm being totally serious because
initially this this train it's got a
hundred cars 100 plus and 50 of them
derailed and they caught fire and a half
mile of this town was just on fire whoa
and then they were like well it turns
out we've got a lot of chemicals on here
and so we need to do something about
that we're also they'll pressurize and
explode and we'll send shrapnel
everywhere so the best thing we can do
is have a controlled burn this is
interesting because how can the
Environmental Protection Agency tell you
the air is clean when they haven't
released the full list of chemicals that
were on board these cars they also one
of them I believe it's uh vinyl chloride
can settle on surfaces and you have to
clean it because it's colorless you
don't know it's there unless you test
for it you know it's funny hearing the
story after Joe Biden just talked about
toxic burn pits in the State of the
Union Address you know in his son and
cancer and all that stuff and it's just
like this sounds this sounds like it's a
lot worse than that this sounds really
really bad but don't worry they lifted
the evacuation order so everyone should
go back to their houses here wait what
is that map you're looking at is it the
water table Yeah so I have a picture of
the Ohio River Basin aquifer and so this
I find this really interesting so you
showed the radius of like basically as
the air flows but this is as um water
travels through the Ohio river which a
couple different cities are starting to
pick up that there are actually
chemicals in the water there it flows
basically from Pennsylvania through West
Virginia all the way through Tennessee
and Kentucky this is interesting to me
uh I'm not going to go conspiracy here
but this is a region I have been
introduced to as pencil Tucky which
overwhelmingly supported Donald Trump it
also has a lot of poverty and uh not a
lot of great health care so it's
interesting that as the water becomes
contaminated it's in this specific
region of the country again coincidental
it's where the Train derailed but well
it's just it it's giving me Flint
Michigan Vibes it's giving me the
Michigan and CDC Vibes too yeah you know
like this the if the if the uh you mean
just government lying to you about
safety in general exactly well there's
also like there's also
um people who are kids are taking a tick
tock that live in the area and they're
saying that FEMA hasn't showed up that
basically people are displaced and that
they have no food and no resources the
Red Cross has not shown up and that the
churches and the restaurants are feeding
the Refuge the refugees of East
Palestine Ohio we have this very low-res
photo of the water basin the Ohio River
the good news is you know we're right
here so we're we're our drinking water's
okay but that wind so the accidents
right up here the wind is all pouring
right over us we are smack dab right in
the right on the on the right side
Eastern side of this thing and we don't
and there's no there's only one chemical
listed that they know there's a leash
four at this point but they don't they
haven't released a complete list well
Newsweek says full list of toxic
chemical Vehicles released from the Ohio
train derailment so uh after I published
that what is what is this phos Gene used
during World War One what is this yeah
the chemicals were diverted into a
trench and burnt officials warned
however that it would send toxic gases
phos Gene used during World War One and
hydrogen chloride into the atmosphere
environmental Regulators have been
monitoring the air and drinking water on
the site for of the derailment and have
so far said both remain unaffected by
this bill yeah I don't believe them how
can that be true when uh the Water the
fish are all dead yeah the fish are dead
and the Water Management Birds
everywhere too red birds yeah yeah
there's people reporting there's like
the birds are just no nothing to see
here buddy everything's fine well and
also
my thing is if it's safe why isn't Biden
visiting why isn't Kamala visiting every
time we have a natural disaster
the fact that there's no significant
reaction from the the government blows
my mind they don't want to talk about it
oh what do you mean I'm I'm surprised
they're usually at least trying to get
in and have I mean they're arresting uh
the Press right journalists the reporter
got arrested I mean they're trying to
cut they're trying to do everything they
can to keep it quiet usually they would
I imagine they would try to get people
on the ground to do the keeping of quiet
I just I disagree with the cabinet
member that feels more like a movie
response maybe like we watch movies and
the government comes in with FEMA and
all that stuff but in reality we we
learn about the the corroding pipes in
Flint and literally nothing happens for
five years or whatever they're just like
oh geez would you look at that and then
nothing happens I see I feel like the
stuff with with flint and the stuff
that's going on in Alabama those are
municipal those are municipal problems
those are problems that the the local
governments uh failed to provide for
their their constituents yeah I guess
this would be like Buddha judge
jurisdiction right well I mean sure
State Commerce and transport absolutely
it would be it would fall to the the
transportation department
um there was a Buddha judge huh you know
we get President Biden and he tells us
we're going to get a Buddha judge you
know we all say okay and then what huh
he's too busy train blows up he's too
busy you know giving his his you know
feeding his new baby I mean you're
taking time off so they can they can be
new dads I could be wrong here right but
I haven't even seen a bite in our
prayers are with the people of East
Palestine not effective I haven't seen
anything nothing I mean that's pretty
cold isn't it to just say like this
chemical train is derailed and we're
gonna burn it and you guys just hang
tight and we'll see what happens I mean
it is the the lack of response should
tell everyone in Ohio what the
administration thinks of their safety
right now we have two super chats one
says I live 10 minutes away from it and
it's not great but not catastrophic and
someone else said boiling liquid
expanding Vapor explosion very bad 1001
ratio so you know it's we'll put in the
middle we'll say it's like moderately
catastrophic but not apocalyptic there
was a fire chief in the area who
responded to this and he said everyone
should go to the doctor and get a record
of their health right now because it's
the question the long-term effects right
wow so maybe you're okay you can go back
to your house but if you develop cancer
or liver cancer specifically or leukemia
or some of the other things then you
need to be able to look back and say was
this because today markers already or
was this because of what I was expecting
okay okay so here we have a list from
Newsweek of what contaminated the air
soil and water surrounding the crash
sites Vinyl chloride a colorless gas
that is used to make polyvinyl chloride
PVC it's uh what we used for plumbing
Plastics and it's highly flammable
really I didn't know that and decomposes
to make toxic fumes okay didn't know
that either according to the National
Library of Medicine it is also
carcinogenic and can cause other health
issues shocker butyl acrylate a clear
liquid that is used for making paints
sealants and adhesives it is flammable
and can cause skin eye and respiratory
irritation
ethylhexyl acrylate a colorless liquid
used to make paints and Plastics it also
causes skin and respiratory irritation
and under moderate heat can produce a
hazardous vapor and ethylene glycol
monobutyl a callless liquid using the
solvent for paints and inks as well as
some Dry Cleaning Solutions it is
classed as acutely toxic able to cause
serious or permanent injury highly
flammable Vapors can irritate the eyes
and nose and ingestion can cause
headaches and vomiting and I'm pretty
sure ethylene glycol is antifreeze
is antifreeze and uh yeah yeah so I
don't know what monobutyl butyl means
but I'm pretty sure you don't want to
ingest or inhale anything related to
antifreeze although I guess technically
propylene glycol is an anti-freezing
agent they use we used to use those on
airplanes back at O'Hare and uh you know
they say it's fine but I would not
recommend like they we got crazy stories
in the airport one guy told a story
about how a guy in a cherry picker you
drive around these trucks with a with a
big hose that would spray propylene
glycol and he once saw his buddy and he
was like hey yeah then blasted them with
this fire hose of this orange goo why do
women live longer we just don't know
yeah no the the answer is allude us you
know the men doing the science and
research but uh yeah so it sounds like
antifreezes you can blast it up into the
air too so you know that's that's that's
wait what happened to the guy who got
blasted he was fine I mean I don't know
it's been 20 years maybe
I'm like hanging on I'm like what
happened to him nothing let me just he
got drenched and then got angry and
yelled at his buddy okay you get when
you're when you're up in the in the
cherry picker de-icing these planes you
spray it down with a with a 50 50
Solution that's propylene glycol water
and it's hot and orange okay this melts
the ice and stops it from instantly
refreezing then you you switch to a
denser a propylene glycol which is green
which is long stays on it stays on it
until it can take off and then the wings
heat up making it make it so that ice
can't form
so they say it's fine but when you when
you pull that lever on the hose there's
a cloud of propylene glycol covering
your whole body as the J because it's
not just like do you have to wear a face
mask or anything when you I mean usually
when you're doing it it's very cold
windy and snowing so you don't have to
wear a mask but uh you know you get
covered in this stuff yeah but they they
claim propylene's fine and the
interesting thing is I think they put it
in food like you'll if you go to the gas
station and buy muffins because everyone
knows gas station muffins the epitome of
quality you might see propylene glycol
list in the ingredients is it just
preservative or something I guess it I
guess it simulates uh moist moisture
slightly it's moisture yeah so like yeah
you know you look when you make a
cupcake and it comes out and it's like
gooey and moist yeah but you leave it
out for a little while it gets hard you
know they mix in some of this antifreeze
and then it you know it never freezes it
stays gooey for a long time or
decomposes I mean if you leave it on
your windowsill for three years
I mean to me to be frank after this
conversation the the the
substance doesn't sound terrifying
anymore at least you know if you put it
in muffins that's you know fine but I
don't know there's plenty of other stuff
that's a lot of bad stuff in muffins
they used to drink mercury in America
yeah just because they put it in the
muffins doesn't mean they should no but
I don't feel like uh you know I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get cancer from that
particular
maybe I mean people are getting cancer
well it's also the digestion versus
inhalation right like think about asthma
and emphysema this could cause lung burn
like this I'm not pro uh chemicals in
the air or anything that that's not the
position that I was taking it's one
muffin it feels
oh my God
you know what it's fine it I mean I
get it like one muffin medium okay but
if you eat them regularly if you eat
them and it's also in all your other
food I mean at the if you smear them on
yourself and let yourself in fire in
your shampoo and it's also in all sort
of stuff like I think that's the hard
thing about being a consumer and a
consumer in America we don't really know
all of the stuff that gets put into our
food that then we eat well there's no
way yeah he doesn't do their job anymore
no right like I I just got back from
Europe in November I went for five weeks
and we've been traveling all over the
world forever there's a there's a
difference of quality in the food in
America now than than there is in Europe
because they actually you have to have
food you can't have food like products
there's there's even regular things like
Oreos or Chips Ahoy or regular snacks if
you compare the the list of what is
allowed in the in America in the food
versus what's allowed in Europe it's
vastly it's different people that people
are pointing out that propylene glycol
is Vape liquid and I looked it up real
quick and the Wikipedia actually
explains de-icing which is cool to read
because it's literally what I did you
know 20 years ago man it's been like 20
it's been 18 years and I think it's
funny that people are like ah it's just
Vape fluid we inhale that stuff and I'm
like bro that's that's airplane
anti-freeze
it's like maybe it's not toxic and
that's what they're saying it's they use
it because it's a non-toxic alternative
people smoke angel dust too it's from
it's like a cigarette dipped in
formaldehyde like good luck yeah yes
people do a lot of things like vaping's
not good for you but what if you Vaped
everything you'd ever Vape in one breath
and then get to continue living in your
town right like a little bit of
something over a long period of time is
one thing a massive amount of something
for days on end is very different
vape and then it's another thing to to
vape continuously breath for you know
two months there's a difference between
you know if you wear construction then
you run an air hammer and you break
concrete versus being in 911 right it's
a huge difference like this not your
body can't take the
the become the impact yeah and I think
it's the transparency that concerns me
right so we're hearing the air is fine
don't worry about it and then we're
starting to hear oh well the water over
here is not so great the water over here
might have some questions uh the fish
are dead thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time